what's going on guys this is rob and i
apologize ahead of time you might hear
some beating in the background they're
actually doing some construction here at
the office uh but you guys have been
asking me to make videos talking about
peacemaker and i don't know you guys are
interested in that but yeah i would love
to talk about peacemaker um so let's
kind of do a bit of a recap right kind
of a review at least in the first three
episodes if you guys want me to do like
kind of like an episodic review as each
episode comes out or like i don't know
maybe do like a breakdown or something
like that let me know down in the
comments section right what do you guys
want to see me do in relation to uh to
peacemaker right so um yeah let's talk
about it
in all honesty i don't really want to be
a negative nancy here and even if i was
going to be
there really isn't much to be negative
about right and in terms of the question
what do i dislike about the peacemaker
show there really isn't anything to
dislike about this show i mean no show
is perfect but there really isn't a
whole lot to to gripe about i mean i
think it's got great pacing i think that
the the tone is great um so i guess the
real question here is what do i like
about this show well first things first
it's amazing
pacemaker is phenomenal in terms of of
john cena right as peacemaker one of the
funny things about this is he's
basically his own comedic relief i mean
vigilante is also a comedic relief of
sorts but it's rare that you ever see
the main star of like a show or a movie
being their own comedic release at least
in relation to like comic book tv shows
and movies i mean you get it
occasionally right like deadpool or
something like that but like if you look
at ant-man right the character of luis
right played by michael pina he's
basically the comedic relief for the
film and paul rudd is like the main star
of the ant-man films which by the way
i'm gonna put this out there
surely i'm not the only one who wants to
see a movie
where like deadpool and luis team up
come on
[Laughter]
tell me that would not be absolutely
magical it would be magic god it would
be phenomenal right that movie would be
absolutely hilarious but but back on
point um let's kind of talk about the
individual characters and the story so
far right so the whole thing with the
butterflies i saw a lot of reviews
online where people were like i mean
this is a pretty basic and stupid plot
but in all honesty i think it's perfect
the great thing about peacemaker
especially coming out of the suicide
squad we were introduced to his
character is that he's a character that
you can't really take seriously you do
but you don't right you almost kind of
see him as like a goof or a buffoon and
when you go into the peacemaker show you
pretty much see him the exact same way
that you saw him coming out of suicide
squad right he's very batman s you guys
remember that meme the batman meme or
batman's like i cherish my no killing
rule i don't care how many men women and
children have to die in order for me to
keep it like that kind of a thing right
the the little moments there that you
got that sure he was cool and he had
like some intense moments and when it
comes down to it peacemaker is a guy you
want on your side but those small little
glimpses of there being something beyond
him just being buffoonish could only
really be expanded on here in the show
and as you're watching this you start to
learn there's a lot that goes on here
once you actually meet robert patrick
and you meet his dad then like it's as
soon as i saw his dad and like as soon
as you're introduced like the tone and
like how was that axe and all that kind
of stuff my thought was john cena's
character never had a chance right being
raised by that guy he never had a chance
of normal life i mean literally he was
taught to be a killer since the day he
was born but like there's a big
difference between like hearing amanda
waller say that and then actually
meeting his dad and realizing oh yeah i
mean it's not as though his dad was
doing it to like protect him or teach
him how to be safe in a world that was
otherwise chaotic filled with all kinds
of people with powers no robert
patrick's character is just a dick so
like literally he just taught his son
how to kill because he's just a really
crappy person so there's a little bit of
drama there right like you look at that
and you're like damn i mean he never
really had a chance at a good childhood
like his dad stole that from him in
terms of robert patrick's character i'm
really excited to see where they go with
that right the whole white dragon thing
like when he's arrested and he's sitting
in jail and like you think those guys
that see him are gonna like kill him and
then like they get over to them they
bend down on one knee and they're like
white dragon and i was like okay so like
this is crazy admittedly even though
i've been reading comic books for a long
long time i don't really know a whole
lot about peacemaker so in a lot of ways
i'll probably have to end up going back
and doing a whole bunch of research
right just looking up a whole bunch of
stuff reading some old comics from you
know 40 years ago and all that kind of
good stuff right sort of you know get
myself caught up on on the peacemaker
mythos but i don't know how accurate the
depiction of his father is to the comics
and even in the context of the show it
doesn't matter right the character
robert patrick is great so i'm really
excited to see what direction they end
up going in the other funny thing and
i'm pretty sure i got this that i have
this correct right leota is the daughter
of amanda waller right like that's the
whole thing behind her like she's the
daughter of amanda waller but like no
one knows i'm excited to find out what's
gonna happen when everybody else finds
out but the other great thing about this
is that as different as this is in a lot
of ways it's also very familiar right
like clemson is by all standards
measurement a mini amanda waller not
nearly as brutal as amanda waller was
not nearly as as cold-hearted as amanda
waller but like the mission has to be
accomplished i don't care who you kill
the mission has to go on right when you
have that scene before you knew that the
kids were possessed and you have like
the whole family in the house like
literally clemson is like take the shot
and it's just like damn he's gonna tell
peacemaker to like kill some kids which
is like a crazy thing but like he tells
them like take the shot even if you have
to take them out it's collateral damage
whatever right small price to pay to
take out what is or what will be a
massive threat which turns out to be a
huge threat because literally these
things are all over the world right like
it's spread all across the world but
again you know it's things like that
that really i don't really think do a
whole lot in terms of clemson i mean
they build him up right they they offer
an explanation there it builds up
peacemaker because like this guy who
puts on this persona right i care about
peace i don't care how many men women
and children i have to kill in order to
get it right suddenly you realize he's
full of [ __ ] right like literally he's
standing there with a sniper rifle and
you would think a guy who's so dedicated
to peace right who doesn't care who has
to die in order for him to get it you
think he would have just been like clear
shot bam right and that's it right this
this kids don't matter but he's like
hesitating like he can't do it and in
fact vigilante ends up being the one to
step up to do it in the first place so
or i guess really after after peacemaker
so that kind of depth right the idea
that like there's just there's a little
more right the more you peel back the
more you realize there is to peel back
is is phenomenal development for john
cena's character but again overall in
terms of the show here's what's so great
about this right peacemaker is a show
that we needed and here's the reason why
those of you guys who have been watching
comic book movies tv shows for a pretty
long time you guys know about this kind
of stuff for those of you guys who are
new to it what makes shows like
peacemaker and even invincible and
movies like deadpool different is that
it is the deadpool effect right i mean
this happens across all forms of medium
but in relation to like comic books for
example in the early 1990s comic books
were like fast-paced high-octane
hyper-violent right cable gw bridge
x-force white people with pockets and
tech and all that kind of stuff but
every character basically felt the same
even spider-man was all like tech and
and all that kind of stuff like
spider-man 2099 and different things
along those lines deadpool fell rank and
file with all those guys right new
mutants issue number 98 created by rob
liefeld fabian asa he's every character
from that time period ever but then you
get to the late 1990s and joe kelly
starts writing him and then starts
writing it from like a dark humor
perspective then gail simone and then
christopher priest who's actually the
one that made deadpool breaking the
fourth wall the really popular element
but deadpool was different he was wholly
different from virtually anybody else
who was out there and that differing
element is what drove people to latch
onto him because it was something that
you just didn't readily see and he's
been a mainstay ever since when you look
at invincible you look at peacemaker you
look at the irredeemable movie or show
whatever is going to be coming out soon
if you guys never looked up irredeemable
that thing is amazing it's basically the
answer to like what would happen if
superman basically became a hero but
then was corrupted by his own hero
warship and then became a bad guy it's
great right he's called the plutonian
technically he's not really called
superman but like irredeemables get like
a whole thing when you look at stuff
like that it's a break away from the
norm right as much as i love the marvel
cinematic universe you can set your
watch to an mcu movie the difference
between a movie like the eternals in a
movie like spider-man no way home is
that the formulaic method of the marvel
cinematic universe movie method can be
felt in eternals you feel it when you
sit down and you watch eternals yes it
looks pretty right and yes the writing
is really really really nice all that
kind of stuff but like you feel the
standard three-act narrative from the
marvel cinematic universe right the set
up the conflict and the resolution you
just see it all over the place when you
watch spider-man no way home it's there
but it's masked by like andrew garfield
jumping through a portal ripping his
mask off and everybody losing their
minds and it's masked by like dr octopus
showing up on the bridge and fighting
tom holland right the green goblin and
spider-man getting into a fight in the
hallway or the death of aunt may it's
covered by all of those like really big
and hype and exciting elements and so
when you look at those from what they
are they're pretty formulaic but then
you come across peacemaker right which
in a lot of ways violates and really
flies in the face of the standard of
what you're used to when it comes to
comic book movies and shows and things
like that and that's what makes it great
that's what makes it so fun and so
exciting so i absolutely love peacemaker
i adore this show and i am so excited
for it uh and i'm i'm excited to see
where it goes do i think we're gonna get
a season two i don't know i haven't seen
the news on whether or not a season two
has been approved for peacemaker i have
to believe that given the level of
popularity that it's getting in terms of
just great reviews it probably will but
i don't know the numbers at the end of
the day that's what it really comes down
to right i mean if five people watch
peacemaker and they all say this is the
greatest show ever it's not gonna mean
much in the face of the fact that only
five people watched it
right it's just it's not worth it's not
worth the amount of money that they're
spending right like how much money are
they getting back in terms of new people
subscribing to hbo max to watch
peacemaker versus people who are just
already subscribed and are watching it
right how much more money is it
generating that's the question they want
to have an answer to so if you guys know
let me know down in the comment section
if you guys know how many people are
actually watching peacemaker right if
it's like of uh like a super well
watched show or if it's just like a few
people here and there i don't really
know i mean it's not really a number i'm
i'm gonna go and research on my own i'm
just kind of curious but regardless yeah
peacemaker's phenomenal absolutely love
it but let me know down in the comment
section if you guys want us to do more
peacemaker stuff right episode
breakdowns and different things like
that easter eggs stuff you miss right
because the the peacemaker mythos is
something i'm a little fuzzy about the
dc mythos i'm pretty damn knowledgeable
on so i could find all kinds of little
easter eggs and different things like
that across the show right because
there's shazam easter eggs in the first
three episodes right there's references
to superman right there's batman easter
egg some wayne enterprises stuff that
appears in there so let me know if you
guys want to see those kinds of things
in the in the in the future videos that
we do on peacemaker but thank you all
for watching and i will catch you all
later
peace